Thomas is with us Thomas is in Tucson
Arizona
hi Thomas how are you here Andy the
pleasure to talk to you
you too sir what's up so I had a
conversation with the co-worker last
night about baby step for saving 15% of
your income and I was going through you
know that different options and you know
that mutual funds and stuff and he says
wait a second Thomas you're a devout
Christian and your church teaches you
not to to gamble let's not gambling this
well he says the stock market is a
hypothetical it's you know ye oh no ifs
can go up or down doesn't matter if this
has a rate of return of 15% in the last
15 years or 20 years he doesn't get to
define gambling he's not Webster's okay
just because he wants to be a cynic is
it you know he doesn't get the
opportunity to define gambling gambling
is defined differently than investing
and whether you agree that whether you
want to call an investment high risk and
you want to say well that risk you know
I don't like for instance I don't like
putting money into gold I think it's a
bad place to put money but I don't call
it gambling it's a it's a hot ultra
high-risk volatile investment but it's
not gambling it's a dumb investment I
would tell you not to do it but it's not
gambling gambling is truly a random act
of chance the fall of a card the roll of
a die those kinds of things is a random
act of chance and and investing is not
that at all and for him to compare the
two is an indication of his personal
cynicism it's not an indication that
you've spiritually screwed up okay does
that make sense yes it does and in
talking to him he explained it is you
know yeah it has a great return that's
been positive in the last 10 years yeah
and the right of return is based on
something it's not based on the random
fall of a dice or card I
I would you know I've listened to your
podcast for years and I tend to agree
with that and I've been excited to get
to this step in my life yeah you know
it's no so I thought I'd call yeah he's
just he's full of crap
it's sad that he's that cynical in that
beat-up but he's basically he's decide
The Wall Street is boogeyman and he
can't define it and he can't understand
it and so he's got to completely you
know poopoo it if you don't want to put
money in mutual funds because you don't
like the level of risk and there are
variables there that you don't have
control over fine but that doesn't make
it gambling it's not gambling at all you
can study a series of stocks and look at
the assets of those companies the income
that those companies produce the track
record of those companies and as a group
you can in a mutual fund you can predict
that and is it perfectly accurate no but
what you're betting on here is a what's
your what you're speculating on what
you're investing based on is not just
whether a horse wrens wins a race or
whether a football team wins a game that
is completely completely wrong to put
those in the same category okay does
that help you it does could ask you one
more question sure I have repaid thirty
three thousand dollars off in three
years we have seven thousand dollars up
so and then we hope to cruise to baby
step three and in the end of this
fifteen percent that's where we were
talking about it and my employer is is
paying off this last seven thousand
dollars over a couple of years I think
we could blow through it in a couple
months but I wonder why is your employer
paying off your debt I don't understand
it's it's a part they get for working
for them they take how much student
loans you have and they divide it by how
many years are willing to pay off and
then know essentially reimburse you at
the end of the year what I would do is
put that much extra in your emergency
fund until they pay it off even though
it's like okay just in case they don't
in case you left the job okay so they go
broke those kinds of things okay and
then you can call yourself debt free
once we have that they covered the 7,000
we could call yourself that freak the
emergency fund plus the 7,000 yeah then
your baby step three yeah that's exactly
how I'd do it just and then make sure
it's covered and then if something bad
goes wrong and you know you find out
there's an integrity problem there you
don't work there anymore you're not
trapped oh I got to stay is there gonna
get my seven thousand I you know you
just write check pay off your debts and
move on if you had to in a bad situation
and hope
run into that I hope it works out for
you but that's the kind of stuff you
don't want this to become golden
handcuffs that's what we want to avoid
so hey man thanks for the call
we appreciate you joining us
you